doch wird ihnen präsentiert von 100
elektrischen nissan leaf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie nennt man das schweizer parlament
und wie setzt es sich zusammen die
bundesversammlung
welches ist der höchste berg der schweiz
der höchste berg der schweiz das ist der
die dufourspitze mit 3000 moment
entschuldigung ich habe etwas
verwechselt 4210 meter das stimmt nicht
ganz
das stimmt nicht es sind 4234 und daher
stimmt ich habe alles verwechselt also
zwei fehler habe ich gemacht
[Musik]
wir haben diesen schritt nie gewagt weil
zuerst war es die sprache
und dann waren die kinder wichtiger und
an die arbeit und noch mehr arbeit
so ist die zeit vergangen
wir sind bald da
ganz tief durchatmen das schweizer
einbürgerungsverfahren ist das strengste
in ganz europa
zwar gibt es nur einen schweizer pass
aber über 2000 wege ihn zu bekommen
das entspricht der anzahl gemeinden in
unserem land zum ersten mal haben
kommunale behörden in allen vier
sprachregionen zutritt zu ihren sehr
vertraulichen anhörungen gewährt bei dem
entscheidenden schritt vor der
kommission müssen die bewerberinnen und
bewerber ihres wissens unter beweis
stellen und zeigen dass sie das
räderwerk dass unser land antreibt bis
ins kleinste detail kennen
willkommen in der einbürgerungs fabrik
bei far east africa des vize schweizer
machen sind wir hier richtig
viele leute stress die einbürgerungs
anhörung derart dass sie fast
zusammenbrechen ganz ganz ruhig es wird
schon gut gehen
wir machen kurz die einführung
wir versuchen die zeit einzuhalten 20
minuten
ja wir fangen schon mit ein bisschen
verspätung an in lausanne müssen bis
ende 2020 auf hochtouren über 1600
bewerbungsdossiers abgearbeitet werden
diese wurden noch unter dem alten gesetz
eingereicht so auch dass der benedetto
scheitern die beiden italiener fangen
sie wieder bei null an einer von fünf
bewerbenden wird hier im durchschnitt
abgewiesen ich fange mit ihnen an frau
benito
warum wollen sich wehren unsere ganze
familie lebt hier
außerdem bin ich seit fast 50 jahren in
der schweiz ich habe mich um meine
kinder gekümmert habe gearbeitet und die
einbürgerung immer wieder aufgeschoben
ich wollte den schritt gehen aber ich
habe gehofft dass es von alleine
passiert
in all den jahren haben wir uns gut
integriert in die französische sprache
und die fünf grössten schweizer städte
zu nennen
perfekt zwei flüsse der rhein und die
rhone
die rhone entspringt dem wallis sie
fließt durch den genfer see verlässt die
schweiz in genf und mündet ins
mittelmeer der rhein entspringt dem
kanton graubünden schließt durch den
bodensee verlässt die schweiz in
schaffhausen und mündet in die nordsee
wissen sie es gibt schweizer die das
nicht so genau wissen gratulation machen
wir mit geschichte weiter geografie
politikgeschichte egal was sie über die
schweiz wissen wollten
das ehepaar benedetto weiß auf alles
eine antwort
welche daten sind wichtig in der
schweizer geschichte der geburtstag der
schweiz 1291 also der bundesbrief
zwischen den kantonen uri schwyz und
unterwalden auf dem rückweg noch einen
angriff datum der wiener kongress von
dort wurde die neutralität der schweiz
erklärt und die grenzen so festgelegt
wie sie heute sind
dann nennen sie einige wichtige daten in
der waadtländer geschichte 1536 nahmen
die berner das waadtland ein und
brachten den protestantismus
dann gibt es noch ein anderes datum 1803
ist das waadtland der eidgenossenschaft
beigetreten
das stimmt als gemeinderätin ist dieser
auftrag hier sinnvoll
damit würdige ich das engagement dass
diese menschen aus dem ausland für die
schweiz bringen
das ist sehr wichtig und 2003
3 oder die kantonale verfassung realität
viele ausländerinnen und ausländer
lassen sich wie die pensionierten
benedictus erst im fortgeschrittenen
alter einbürgern
die doppelte staatsbürgerschaft war
lange verboten und eine einbürgerung
teuer denn die kosten richten sich nach
dem einkommen und konnten sich auf
mehrere tausend franken belaufen
seit 2006 dürfen die behörden nur noch
die verfahrenskosten berechnen dennoch
gibt es große unterschiede in lausanne
wird man für 800 freundin eingebürgert
fast viermal weniger als in freienbach
dort muss andreas 2900 franken bezahlen
aber da braucht es schon mehr um den
bewerber aus der ehemaligen ddr zu
entmutigen
[Musik]
ziemlich viel
andreas hat den kantonalen
einbürgerungstest gestanden sein
verfahren läuft weiter er wird von der
gemeindeschreiberin vorgeladen in
unserem land wo die einheimischen beim
thema geld lieber schweigen müssen sich
die einbürgerungswilligen bis auf die
unterhosen ausziehen
das ist das doppelte gebrauchen konnte
andreas dachte sein verfahren würde
endlich vorankommen
doch der bürokratische weg ist kafkaesk
bis er die fehlenden dokumente erhält
sind andere möglicherweise bereits
wieder abgelaufen
im sportverein pistolenschießen beck
aber in altendorf lachen das ist mit
sich eine zwingende die freie woche
fragt sie sehen die meine freien jetzt
so nicht gesehen
auf ihrem lebenslauf start der seite
ihrer hobbys ist angeln aber das habe
ich zurzeit hier nicht ausübt leider
nicht gut gemacht denn die behörden
fragen
neben ambition in der polizei und dann
machen wir machen
[Musik]
seit acht monaten wartet david auf
diesen brief für den eritreischen
flüchtling und seine familie ist das ein
entscheidender schritt in ihrem
einbürgerungsverfahren ok aufgebot zur
einbürgerung die 14-jährige ermittler
ist ebenfalls eingeladen bezug auf 4 1
während sich die familie für das
orthodoxe fest des heiligen michael
bereit macht wird er miller bewusst was
ihr vater alles auf sich genommen hat um
den schweizer pass zu bekommen
am anfang hatte ich keine ahnung aber er
hat mir alles erklärt zuerst glaubte ich
es sei ganz einfach dabei später habe
ich verstanden dass man extrem viele
sachen machen muss und dass es gar nicht
so einfach ist wie sich aus er hat sich
extrem engagiert
er kam spät abends nach der arbeit nach
hause und fing sofort an zu lernen
am nächsten tag ging er zur schule dann
kam er heim lernte wieder
er hat sich wirklich mühe gegeben seht
ihr ab geht wegen eines kurzen
spitalaufenthalts nicht mit in die
kirche behält aber ihre familie trotzdem
im auge
diese schuhe hier angezogen
welche schuhe hast du angezogen
ich habe extra daniela kocht schuhe
geputzt dies jedoch holen sie sind im
schrank
sie möchte unbedingt dass wir alle in
weiß in die kirche gehen also ziehen wir
uns alle weiß an und einige frau david
kinder kennen nur lugano
das ist weit weg von eritrea wo ihr
vater aufgewachsen ist durch die
gemeindefeste will david seinen kindern
ihre wurzeln näher bringen
[Musik]
andreas macht es nichts aus stundenlang
auto zu fahren um seine familie zu
besuchen
sie lebt verstreut über ganz deutschland
[Musik]
dieses wochenende besucht er seine
älteste tochter saskia um seine zweite
enkelin kennenzulernen
begleitet wird andreas von seiner
partnerin birgit der mutter seiner
jüngsten tochter lisa gemeinsam haben
sie lange in freienbach gewohnt vor
einem jahr ist birgit auf der suche nach
arbeit nach deutschland zurückgekehrt
andreas ist allein zurückgeblieben
trotzdem ist er fest entschlossen
schweizer bürger zu werden
ohne seine familie hätte andreas kaum
einen grund nach deutschland
zurückzukehren
denn dabei reißen alte wunden auf für
mich eben unterschied zwischen
bundesrepublik und schweiz ist in
westdeutschland und die erfahrung
gemacht ja der österreichisches weniger
wert bei 30 jahre nach der wende
wenn das aus
der schweiz hat man eben wenig mehr
chancen und da zählt man mehr als mensch
für direkte
[Musik]
nach dem mauerfall wurde andreas den
stempel aus sie nie mehr los und fühlte
sich von den westdeutschen als verlierer
der geschichte abgestempelt andreas er
trug diesen hohen nicht und zog in die
schweiz
[Musik]
das ist eine natürliche verwerfung
sie verläuft ganz und man auf dem krone
des nils wie jedes jahr plant die
familie corona cardoso die ferien in der
touristischen nebensaison ihrer
wahlheimat seit 30 jahren leben die
hotelangestellten in pontresina und
arbeiten den ganzen sommer vor der
bevorstehenden einbürgerungs anhörung
erholt sich die italienische
portugiesische familie in annas
heimatstadt abrantes wenn du klinik 7
oder jugend anderes leben sind alle
miteinander spielen
nein er wohnt mit seiner freundin
zusammen
sieh mal an die zeit raus familie
freunde und der nächste huster wenn die
man die tochter so freut hätte da wieder
zurückkommt was ich dass ich immer schön
jetzt hast du das foto verdorben
selbst in den ferien können die
unermüdliche nicht aus ihrer haut
es scheint eine berufskrankheit zu sein
bei familie koordinator so wird selbst
das kleinste familienessen zum festmahl
da die mannschaft mitgehen
du weißt jetzt dass man sich bei uns
drei kirchen ging der richter größte
freuen wohin sobald ich zurückkomme
standorte die ganze familie oder großer
verzicht ganzes jahr
und wenn du kein staat machen
auch wie gut dass ich alles so spontan
redog der familie was gibt's neues
leider nicht so wie heute das ist schon
ziemlich militante und blues schon lange
mit sich
hier kann ich eigentlich einmal
regelmäßig essen
das ist toll in der schweiz schaffe ich
es mit all dem stress und arbeit nicht
etwas vernünftiges
als anna und paul und die schweiz kamen
standen sie ganz unten auf der sozialen
leiter und mussten für ein besseres
leben kämpfen
stein auf stein haben sie sich hier ein
traumhaus gebaut klagen dass mir sind
kohlen die spitzen geld verdiene
aber als ich nicht nur geld verdient und
alles drei schicke ich mache dir ganz
normales leben wie schwitzen oder wo es
wohnt die schweizer verdient die schweiz
und schlichtete werde rosinus land wir
denken mit einer feder rosinus land
quasi sehr schön
diese zahl haben so eine art zu gehen
ich finde sie stellen den cops relegant
mit investor die finde ich sehr wichtig
heute sind andere und barolo stolz dass
ihre tochter eine kindheit bieten können
von der sie nie zu träumen wagten den
cern will ich mich einfach frei ich
denke an nichts anderes mehr bett ist
mein ziel ist es die schule in konz
tessiner fertig zu machen und dann eine
lehre zu beginnen und dann kann ich je
nach portugal kommen an die universität
von cambridge wie alle jungen leute mit
einem c ausweis kann sich auch chiara
nicht komplett frei bewegen damit sie im
ausland studieren kann braucht sie eine
genehmigung von den schweizer gehört
ansonsten zählt ihre komplette kindheit
in der schweiz nicht mehr mit dem pass
wäre diese gefahr gebannt
obwohl chiara noch jung ist muss sie
bereits nächstes jahr entscheiden was
sie in zukunft machen
in der schweiz haben junge menschen
viele perspektiven und sich eine bessere
zukunft und ein sicheres leben
aufzubauen
hallo
also stellt gerade in stuttgart jagt ein
besuch den nächsten
jetzt darf andreas jüngste tochter ihre
neue nicht kennenlernen
lisa ist flugbegleiterin und lebt in
berlin
nachdem ihr einbürgerungsgesuch vor fünf
jahren abgelehnt worden war kehrte sie
freienbach und damit auch dem großteil
ihrer jugendzeit den rücken
mit zwölf jahren mehr hingezogen ich
habe meine teenager jahre verbracht
teilweise auch in die jungen jungen
erwachsenen jahre rein und es ist meine
heimat
allein schon dadurch dass alle meine
freunde schweizer waren und habe also
auch eingebürgerte schweizer aber das
hat man ja natürlich nie offensichtlich
mitgekommen mitbekommen das waren halt
meine freundin das waren halt schweizer
die beziehung wie man da hatte lisa war
auf gutem weg schweizerin zu werden sie
hatte alle hürden gemeistert
es fehlt nur noch die anhörung vor der
gemeinde die erinnerung an dieses
gespräch geht ihr immer noch unter die
haut da habe ich mich wirklich unter
druck geführt habe so war ich auch
manche sachen nicht wusste wie zb dieses
naturschutzgebiet oder aber zum beispiel
die sportarten habe ich zum beispiel und
snowboarden gesagt dass
im internet jasmin schwing und pornos
sind sie nicht überspringen konnte
wusste ich noch daran auch öfter auf
festen und meine ganzen schweizer
freunde wussten natürlich davon
schwimmen weil das ist ja auch sehr groß
sind eine generation aber hornos 1 stein
werfen gar nicht und wo dann immer
weiter und weiter nach einer antwort
gefragt wurde wirklich eine antwort
gefordert wurden als ich wenn ich dann
keine antwort bringen konnte das dann
[Musik]
negative antworten kann nicht im sinne
von von wirklichen aussagen aber das
dann halt einfach mal mit der zunge
geschnalzt wurde und das ist das reicht
ja schon mein selters ist allein dass
man selber ist dann allein es war ein
bisschen feucht weil vor allem wenn man
so 20 ist denn überhaupt kein
selbstvertrauen hat in der sache ja bin
ich raus was den saal bin aus dem
schloss raus und hab mir erst mal eine
ecke gesucht und geheult
da habe ich mich kunst niederlage
geführt und einfach nicht mehr zu hören
also ich hab da war wirklich der us open
wo ich gedacht habe was mache ich denn
jetzt wenn wenn meine heimat nicht mehr
um meine heimat sein möchte oder wenn
meine heimat mich für meine heimat ist
die behörden kreideten lisa mangelnde
integration und fehlende
selbstfinanzierung an
sie war erst 20 und lebt bei ihren
eltern wie andere in ihrem alter hatte
sie ihr studium unterbrochen und wollte
sich neu orientieren
somit war sie für die gemeinde nicht
mehr studentin das ablehnungsschreiben
kam nicht alleine ihm lag noch eine
schlussrechnung bei 1800 franken
verfahrenskosten
klar wurde der c ausweis nicht
weggenommen ich hatte dir ja noch und
ich hatte ja auch noch mein leben in der
schweiz aber das war so eine zweite
moment wo ich gedacht habe meine heimat
bin ich nicht
andreas wird die geschichte seiner
tochter nicht zum ersten mal aber jetzt
da seine eigene anhörung näher rückt
bekommen lisas worte eine ganz andere
bedeutung
ich hoffe natürlich dass er in dem
gespräch nette leute hat und die ihn
auch dementsprechend entgegenkommen wenn
man ist doch meiner frage habt oder so
aber inhaltlich weiß ich dass ich das
eigentlich ich mich gar nicht sorgen
muss weil er schafft das
[Musik]
frau benito können sie uns sagen was
seine initiative ist also nur auf
bundesebene also eine gez ein moment ich
muss ein bisschen nachdenken ganz ruhig
wozu gibt es initiativen und wie
lanciert das referendum
dann können sie in ruhe überlegen das
referendum ist ein politisches recht mit
dem die bürger gegen einen beschluss des
parlaments vorgehen und was müssen die
bürger dafür tun
die bürger müssen unterschriften sammeln
es braucht acht 1500 unterschriften auf
gemeinde ebene
nein ich wollte es auf bundes auf
bundesebene braucht es für ein
referendum 50.000 in 100 tagen
vielleicht läuft es besser mit der
initiative das ist politisches recht die
bürgerinnen und bürger schlagen ein
gesetz vor
mit dem etwas geändert oder mit dem die
verfassung teilweise geändert werden
soll
hervorragend dann also vielen dank wir
sind am ende dieser anhörung angelangt
das wort hat nun frau treibach die uns
das weitere vorgehen erklärt die
kommission vergleich einem vorentscheid
und übermittelt diese der gemeinde in
lausanne kennen viele der
kommissionsmitglieder den beschwerlichen
weg bis zur einbürgerung aus eigener
erfahrung
ich stamme ursprünglich aus italien
auch wenn keiner aus meiner familie hier
ist weiß ich das früher auch die
italiener oder spanier kämpfen mussten
heute sind sie gut integriert vielleicht
wollten sie ursprünglich in ihre länder
zurückkehren
aber schließlich haben sie hier eine
familie gegründet und wurden heimisch
also blieben sie und setzten sich wir
müssen uns ein bürger
diese französisch ausgezeichnet
integration ebenfalls sie sind
pensioniert und auch alle themenbereiche
perfekt das ist nicht immer der fall
wir hatten glück also los der nächste es
lief sehr gut jetzt ist der stress
vorbei jetzt geht es mir besser
ja auch das resultat bekommen in vier
wochen haben sie uns gesagt vier bis
sechs wochen sechs wochen das ist lang
und trotzdem ist die gemeinde er schnell
wenn man bedenkt dass es im besten fall
eineinhalb jahre dauert bis man den
schweizer pass erhält das fest des
heiligen michael in lugano ist ein
wichtiger treffpunkt für die eritreische
gemeinschaft in davids leben spielt die
religion eine zentrale rolle
ich bin sehr eng mit der orthodoxen
kirche verbunden
seit neun jahren helfe ich bei der
organisation
[Applaus]
es ist ein großes fest und wird bis
morgen dauern
sie ist krank geworden und musste für
eine behandlung ins spital
zum ersten mal in den letzten neun
jahren verpasst sie dieses fest und das
ist vor allem für die kinder schwer
ich hoffe sie kommt bald wieder heim für
mich ist dieses fest wichtig weil die
meisten meiner freundinnen in kia sie
wohnen so können wenn wir alle zusammen
sind und die triererinnen dann bin ich
mich selber weil wir alle aus demselben
land kommen haben wir die gleichen
lebensumstände und ich fühle mich
einfach wohl
es kommen sehr viele eritrea und
äthiopien aus der ganzen schweiz und
sogar aus italien
das kann man wirklich nicht mehr
hinterher
es werden heute abend auch viele
äthiopier kommen denn die kirche ist
jesus christus gesagt hat das haus
meines vaters
eine messe lang spielt die entfernung
zwischen der schweiz und eritrea für
diese katholische kirchgemeinde keine
rolle
[Musik]
wie viele orthodoxe feste dauert auch
dieses die ganze nacht hindurch
aber nicht alle schaffen es bis zum
morgengrauen letztes jahr war ich
wirklich ganz vorne
da waren all die priester und ich habe
mir gesagt du darfst bloß nicht
einschlafen aber einige male als wir uns
von den banken erheben mussten bin ich
sitzen geblieben und eine cousine hat zu
mir gesagt was immer studenten steh auf
es ist mir wichtig bei diesen an hess
und dabei zu sein wenn man kann auch an
gott glauben ohne in die kirche zu gehen
[Musik]
nun
bis 1971 hat nur die männer das
wahlrecht danach auch die frauen und
1981 kam die rechtliche gleichstellung
so wie man ist so ich sage dir das dem
parlament und du schreibst die person
dazu auf ok utilities und polizei
schweizer oder schweizerin zu retten ist
nicht nur eine identitätsfrage sondern
bedeutet auch das erlanger der vollen
bürgerrechte ein viertel der schweizer
bevölkerung besitzt keinen schweizer
pass davon erfüllt fast eine million die
kriterien für eine einbürgerung anna und
paul haben beschlossen aus dieser
stummen minderheit auszubrechen
also los stell mir fragen aber
übertreiben es nicht wie viele stimmen
braucht ein referendum wie viele
unterschriften 50.000 brille wie viele
leute gibt es in der in der
bundesversammlung das weiß ich nicht 246
wie viele stimmen braucht es für das
parlament
mir macht es spaß sollen auf meine
eltern die sachen die ich in der schule
lernen und dann ist es schöner
ich bin nicht die einzige die die sachen
lernen muss bestimmte sache für die
schule mitgenommen und temarii
ziemlich viel
kommt jetzt die gemeinde fand pontresina
bei familie corona cardoso steigt die
anspannung vorfeld bei der anhörung vor
der gemeinde die entscheidung ob sie die
einbürgerung schaffen oder nicht gehört
dem motto das modell zur pontresina oder
salaten und das war das ist nicht wahr
trotzdem scheitern seiner tochter ist
andreas immer noch zuversichtlich
er hat alle noch fehlenden dokumente
eingereicht seine bewerbung wurde nun im
amtsblatt veröffentlicht
freienbach andreas lutter was ich bin
von deutschland wohnsitz in der schweiz
13 jahren einwände oder bemerkungen
innert 20 tagen kann jedermann zu den
eingangs besuchen an bringen dürfte er
nicht in der sache passiert die
kapitalmärkte mit dem stress ich habe
keine politischen probleme machen sie
haben den park nicht regierungen jemand
auf parkplatz andauernd oder
drangsaliere jemand und von daher nicht
einfach das jetzt irgendwie näher sich
daran stört dass sie nicht einbürgern
also überall in der schweiz kommt es vor
dass die behörden anschuldigungen von
bürgern erhalten die gegen eine
einbürgerung sind meistens anonym
märz an ddr-zeiten denke vereinsleben
hat spaß gemacht ja war früher schöne
jugend beim bogenschießen und
luftgewehrschießen aber im
pistolenschießen gab es eben nicht sagen
wir schießen ist mehr schweizerisch es
ist entspannung ja wann schaltet ab man
fokussiert ist mit mit dem blick aufs
ziel und ist einfach entspannung
ja war schon besser als vorher 100 wäre
optimal aber meilenweit von den verein
hat man die vereinsmitglieder mit denen
man bierchen trinken quatsch die zu
veranstaltungen schießen morgen hatten
schießen oder roten turm schießen und
sitzt dann und danach noch und ist eben
was anderes als wenn man alleine
irgendwo schießt und pistolenschießen
ausgibt
tschüss
[Musik]
sie war es in der schule mein papa ist
gar nicht da endlich drei monate nach
verfahrensbeginn ist der große tag für
familie corona cardoso ich bin noch ein
bisschen nervös ich pack das auch die
und sie verleitet das weiß nicht wie das
laufen wie ich das was wird und was so
wie wir das gemacht und wer macht was
gefragt was das macht mir eine schnecke
für thomas walther ist es ein
feierlicher moment
er ist präsident der
einbürgerungskommission und führt die
wenigen anhörungen in seiner gemeinde
mit größter sorgfalt durch in pontresina
gibt es nur drei bis vier im jahr sollen
sich um frances vorbereitetes moossee
wichtigkeit die größte betrieb tk will
meine staatsbürgerschaft ist das konzert
im supermarkt kaufen sondern nahm das
langfristige gewisse konsequenz mit
keinem schweizer schweizerin unter
kritik am 15 das ist ganz okay
ich gewann das glockenprojekt ist auch
schwierig weil die kommission ist liegt
wo du kennst vier jahre auf der straße
oder begrüße ich aber nicht wisse wie
das gott so profitiert und mein gott
jetzt schon heiß
die situation ist nicht ganz angenehm
wir sitzen hier wie eine art tribunal
aber wir haben keine bösen absichten
warum wollte die schweizer werden
papa ich will schweizer werden weil ich
seit 30 jahren bin ich bin gut
integriert und ich bin jetzt etwas
gestresst
ich fühle mich hinter kreiert ich
empfinde mich schon als teil der schweiz
das system im gesamten gefällt mir
also dass sie eben bürger und ruft
wachse also minimal in denen und
portugiesen sind 14 jahren italien
portugal oder italien wo ist die h
aber das leben brauchen wir mehr 2 eine
sehr gut zum beispiel mal vor zwei
wochen hätten wir denn der heutige
spruch wenn wir damit zum tag sind im
team mit ihm automatisch mehr
verständlich also ähnlich und dialekt
und die schweizer verfassung garantiert
gewisse freiheiten und rechte barolo
darf eine übersetzung verlangen der
italienisch zu den kanton sprachen
gehört so ohne weiteres zwischen drei
landessprachen zu wechseln da haben auch
viele schweizer also freie
meinungsäußerung und religionsfreiheit
und wer ist mehr wert die frau oder mann
gleichheit der geschlechter
19 89 71 wir haben der bundeswehr
wie viele haben wir und das ist ihr ein
paar wie sie auch heißen die ac a t
genau wie viele kantone erscheint am 26
das haben wir als erstes wiederholt aber
es sind 26 am ersten märz im engadin
gefeiert september 1000 punkte es gibt
1000 punkte gehen wir jetzt ein bisschen
zum wasser wie heißt der fluss der hier
in pontresina startet nein hier kommen
zwei zusammen und der mündet wo fließt
und fließt wohin der rhein fließt durch
chor der andere fließt woanders durch da
hatte ich ein bisschen angst dass ich
den pass nicht bekommen
wegen diesen blöden blackout stupid
blackout gefühlt also das muss ich sie
jetzt seid ja völlig klar war mir alles
kaputtgemacht nicht kriegt man gerade im
moment nicht gut gehen kann
[Musik]
das schwarze meer
weitere fragen die anhörung geht zu ende
nach der intensiven vorbereitung fast
ein bisschen enttäuschend
wir wissen sogar der präsident des
grossen rates ist 2017 weiß martin wir
wissen auch die namen der vier gipfel
bestiegen sie gehen auf den die berge
zum wandern habt ihr diese gipfel auch
bestiegen
die muss man gemacht haben familie krone
keine schlangen weil man sie nicht kennt
also sind wir sehr viele wieso wird
schwitzen schwitzen werde und dreimal
schwank dort car builder mit dem roten
pass ist es einfach zu reisen
und der muss sagen dass catherine
ausgesprochen
das sind oder sind das keine motivation
zum zum schweizer schweizer 2
jetzt kommt er dreht der kandidat david
mengesdorf geboren 1974 david mengesdorf
ist am 24 februar 1974 in asmara eltern
geboren er hat ein gesuch für sich und
seine drei kinder eingereicht davids und
der melas großer tag gleich müssen sie
der luganer kommission entgegen treten
die beeindruckende 13 mitglieder hat
diese prüfen unter dem vorsitz von enea
petrini das dossier ein letztes mal bis
ins kleinste detail also zu seiner
lebensgeschichte
nach der matura hatte den
obligatorischen militärdienst gemacht
zehn jahre lang also wenn ich das
richtig gelesen habe zehn jahre
da müssen wir vielleicht genauer darauf
eingehen aber ich glaube das ist schon
war im november 2006 entscheidet er sich
sein leben zu ändern kommt hier als
asylsuchende an und bekommt einen
ausweis der besucht italienisch kurse um
das sprachniveau b1 zu erreichen
auch den gesellschafts test hat er
bestanden er ist verheiratet für seine
frau liegt kein gesuch vor weil sie noch
nicht lange genug hier ist es gibt keine
laufenden verhandlungen oder verfahren
und auch keine klagen gegen ihn
begründung für das gesuch meine familie
und ich fühlen uns vollständig in die
wirtschaftlichen sozialen kommunalen
kantonalen nationalen strukturen
integriert danke dann können sie
reinkommen
[Musik]
ich war die jüngste sonst gab es nur
erwachsene
sie haben auch mich gefragt da habe ich
gedacht vielleicht stellen sie mir
fragen auf die ich keine antwort weiß
natürlich ist man gestresst wenn man
diesen raum betreten die bewerber warten
draußen und haben keine ahnung was
drinnen vor sich geht wir wussten dass
da 13 leute seien würden aber wir
wussten nicht was sie uns fragen in
pontresina warten die krone cardosos auf
das ergebnis ihrer einführung
chiara beginnt ein praktikum im hotel wo
ihr vater arbeitet
in freienbach kämpft andreas vor der
einwanderungsbehörde damit nicht
komplett den faden zu verlieren
[Musik]
vor der imposanten kommission von lugano
riskiert david seine einbürgerung und
diejenige seiner familie
[Musik]
dort wurde ihnen präsentiert von 100
elektrischen nissan leaf